ant-man is Marvel's newest addition to
the MCU in this film stars Paul Rudd
Michael Douglas and Evangeline Lilly and
tells a story of Scott Lang this guy's a
thief he's a lowlife he has a daughter
he cares a lot for but he's just a
criminal he's extremely good at breaking
into people's houses and stealing stuff
and one day Michael Douglas Hank Pym
takes note of this and decides to try to
recruit him to become his successor as
ant-man because there's some pretty
serious business going down some end of
the world type stuff of course that
needs to be stopped it's really hard to
believe this now because of the world we
live in with entertainment but when I
was a kid I wondered if we'd ever see a
spider-man live-action film
now we're getting ant-man I mean we're
getting the weirdest of the weird the
smallest quite literally of the small of
popular superhero characters guys guess
what Marvel did it again ant-man is a
lot of fun as a movie I laughed my ass
off consistently throughout this film
Paul Rudd nails it as Scott Lang he is
such a likable addition to the MCU I
loved his portrayal of this character
Michael Douglas oh my gosh to hear his
voice be the voice of Hank Pym was such
a delight he was fantastic in this movie
not just because it's Michael Douglas
and he's talented and it's so nice to
see him in a good movie but they gave
Hank Pym such a good backstory the
film's focus on Michael Douglas and his
daughter as portrayed in the film by
Evangeline Lilly really added a lot of
great depth to this movie and I thought
it really took it in a good direction
and whenever it needed that humor
Michael Pina holy every word out of
that guy's mouth from this movie
perfection comedy gold he was just
rocking it he was nailing every line
another thing I must recommend and
really surprisingly because usually I
don't give a crap about this the 3d
really added something to this movie
because the sequence is where he shrunk
down to size and they blurred out the
background so deeply and the focus was
on this little man running through a
bathtub or down a drainage pipe or
underneath the ground the 3d really
worked for these sequences and added
something that I don't think you could
actually achieve in 2d and that's rare
for me to say because usually 3d just
comes off as a gimmick to me that isn't
actually necessary for the film
in this movie it added something let's
talk about those action sequences
because by far the most entertaining
aspect of the movie visually they are
stunning to look at there isn't a single
aspect of the CGI in this film they're
like CGI not real I think a lot of that
is due to the photorealistic style of
some of this CGI the fact that it really
just looked like a small man running
along these surfaces they did a terrific
job with that CGI in those sequences and
without spoiling anything I like the way
this film tied in to other Marvel movies
they address the thing that people are
always asking well why don't they just
call the Avengers because the Avengers
are amazing
well the Avengers can't always do
everything sometimes you need a small
guy to do a small thing and this movie
was knowingly and willingly small-scale
which is perfect because its hero is
also small-scale I love the fact this
movie didn't need to be some big bloated
extravaganza with tons of stuff just
flying all over the place it understood
that it was a smaller film it's not a
flawless movie though this movie went
through a lot of problems in its
production Edgar Wright was the original
director of this movie and you can
definitely tell they used a lot of his
ideas especially in regards to the
action sequences if you go back and
watch Edgar Wright's original test
footage it looks a lot like the way they
handle the action scenes in this movie
so I'm really glad that in the credits
they did give him story credit that's a
really good thing they did there but I
do wish that he had helmed this movie
because I think he could have brought a
lot more energy more snappy cuts and I
just feel like he could have brought
something to this film that wasn't there
and one of the biggest issues with the
movie is its structure in the first 20
minutes or so it does feel a little
broken it feels like a couple different
movies were happening at once one's very
funny one's more serious and sometimes
that balance isn't always perfect also
there are certain characters in the
movie that just feel like plot devices
for one Scott Lang's daughter in the
film you know what they're gonna do with
her and when they do you're like I was
expecting that also the main villain in
the movie he was a big evil guy who is
really good at being evil I'd like to do
evil things like shrink lambs without
feeling a shred of guilt and his
eventual transformation felt forced it
just it didn't really work for me I
think as a villain he wasn't a very
compelling character they tried to give
him a good backstory and in some aspects
it worked but it just was overshadow
by how funny and awesome movie was which
is a good thing because this movie is
funny the fact that Marvel is able to
take such a strange superhero story a
smaller one a lesser-known one and make
it as entertaining as this film was
really paid off for me I had a ton of
fun watching ant-man
Paul Rudd nailed it as the character
Michael Pina was brilliant Michael
Douglas and Evangeline Lilly were
excellent I love the look of the movie
the action set-pieces were really well
done I just felt that some of the
structure in regards to balancing that
humor and the thrills sometimes didn't
always work a few characters came off
like plot devices and the main villain
just wasn't really that impressive to me
but I had a ton of fun with this movie
and I'm going to give ant-man a B+ also
no spoilers there is a mid-credits scene
and an after credits scene so be sure to
stay for both of them because they're
pretty friggin cool and really quick I
got this awesome poster at tonight's
screening and that is all because there
was a charity group there superheroes
for kids in Ohio these guys dress up
like superheroes and they visit sick
kids in the hospital they do charity
work for kids it's such a cool thing
these guys were at the screen tonight
dressed up like all these characters it
was awesome there's a link in the
description below for their charity work
if you want to donate anything to them
thank you so much guys as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck my niced